yeah that's it okay good afternoon
everyone and welcome to this planning
meeting my name is lawrence walsh and i
am the chair of this
meeting councillor aidan williams is the
vice chair
in attendance we have senior planning
officers together with officers from
legal highways
democratic services and members of
council who make up this
planning committee please be aware that
this meeting will be recorded for
live and for subsequent broadcast on the
council's youtube channel
whole of the meeting will be recorded
except where there are
confidential items or exempt items
this activity promotes democratic
engagement in accordance with section
100
a of the local government act members
are asked to mute their microphone
to minimize background noise if you wish
to speak to an item please use
the chat facility to notify myself and
then
wait till i invite you to speak before
making your comments
please state your name for voting i will
actu
ask each individual member if they are
for or against the officer's
recommendations
so go to the agenda proper
and um attendances i've got apologies
from council stennett
council accordingly and councillor rigby
and we have councillor thomas
substituting for
councillor stinnett thank you councillor
thomas for that we're very grateful for
your attendance
um declarations of interest would any
member members to give notice of any
personal
or prejudicial interest and the nature
of that interest
relating to any item on the agenda in
accordance with the
adopted code of conduct any members like
to declare an interest
well can i council sorry sorry
chairman um i'd like to declare an
interest on
uh foxwood in hale barnes um significant
number of
my uh both my ward chairman and a
significant of my award committee are
affected by this development
i think it's i've probably got a
predator judicial view um
in impact because of that so i'd like i
i will be abstaining on that
um development okay thank you for that
councilman morgan
anybody else uh well actually i need to
declare an
interest in uh the application at
millway
um page 58 the one of the objectives has
had conversations with myself
and uh we don't feel it's appropriate
that i
partake in that meeting so the chair
i'll hand over the chair to councillor
williams
for that item but i i won't be taking
part in that meeting
okay um item number three is the minutes
of the meeting
to receive is so determined to approve
the correct record the minutes of the
meeting held on the 18th
and the 23rd of june 2020 would anybody
like to move those
minutes as a true and correct record
you councillor proctor um
item number four is questions from
members of the public and you understand
that no questions have been
submitted um
okay item number five is the additional
information report you've had site of
that it's been updated this afternoon
and and you'll have that on your uh on
your computer
tablets um ipsum number six is
applications for permission to develop
just a reminder
to everybody um as well as our local
knowledge we look
to the background papers listed at the
beginning of the gender item six
for guidance when making decisions this
evening
um so we were going to go to the
first item on the agenda which was
altering him retail pack at page one we
is that still the case uh miss coleman
uh no no the officer presenting that is
having difficulties logging into the
meeting at present so
uh if if yourself and the committee
members are
um content if we could take another item
first that would be helpful
if um if
if mrs brown isn't able to to join us i
will present that
the first item but for now i'd prefer if
she could
continue to make attempts to join us if
that's okay okay thank you for that miss
coley
so we'll go to page 44 that's fox
foxwood
78 a high elm road hail bands
and we have an introduction from miss
lowe's to this item miss lowe's
thank you chair i will just get the
presentation to share with everybody if
you just bear with me for
two seconds while i um
thank you
okay relate to foxwood at 78a high elm
road in hale barnes
the application has been called in the
committee by um counselor
bus the application property is located
on the south side of high elm road in
the residential area of
hail barns the site includes an area of
woodlands with a large
number of mature trees protected by tree
preservation order to the south and east
of the dwelling
as shown here um on the site plan
and these um mature trees
are protected by tree preservation order
and separate
and the property on the on the southern
and eastern boundary to properties
um in a cul-de-sac the cops
the existing property is a two-story
fact spelling with an integral
integral garage the photograph shows
the existing property and you can see
the mature trees in the background
and the areas where some trees have been
removed
two recent tree preservation order
applications have been granted on the
site
to remove a number of trees seven trees
around
the um the extent of the dwelling this
current proposal does not propose to
remove
any fair trees
the application and seeks to gain
permission for
a remodeling of the dwelling um
including the erection of a single-story
rear extension
and first floor side extension both of
which have been previously approved in
an earlier application
this current proposal also includes the
provision of a roof terrace above the
single story rear extension
the raising of the roof ridge height the
conversion of the roof form to form a
hipped from a hip to roof to a gable end
and also the creation of two front gable
features
along with the erection of a detached
double garage
the key considerations in this
application are the design and
appearance
of the of the extensions
and the impact on residential living
enabling properties
a number of objections have been
received and from the
residential properties to the south in
the um
in the cups the proposed extension and
alterations would sit comfortably within
the street scene
and are of a high quality design and
appearance
due to the significant separation
distances to the the rear and the
retention of all the existing trees
there is not considered to be any under
overlooking towards neighboring
properties
the proposals are considered compliant
with policy l7
and the supplementary planning document
4. the application is therefore
recommended for approval thank you
thank you miss lowes um
if i may could councillor morgan please
just leave the meeting if he said he had
a prejudicial interest so he will need
to
to actually step out we will we'll give
you a a shout when
it's ready for you to come back in
councilor morgan
thank you for that thanks for that
councilor morgan council for that
thanks like miss cauley and we've got a
statement to read out from the agent
from one of our officers um i'm not sure
who's going to read that out
that's myself chairman oh thank you mr
coley
um the the uh the statement is from
center architects
for the agent the chair of the planning
committee ladies and gentlemen
i speak in support of the development
and in the hope i can satisfy any
concerns
raised by neighbours to the property
based on the objections
these concerns are primarily the loss of
privacy loss of trees
loss of visual immunity and the design
not being in keeping with the character
of the area
i would like to say that all these
issues were taken into consideration
when designing the extensions to the
property and were dealt with
should be noted that the site is nearly
half a hectare in area
or nearly one and a quarter acres the
nearest garden boundary from the cops
is 37 meters away the nearest house on
the cops
is 71 meters away although some trees
were removed recently from the site
which was as part of a wooden management
scheme to remove dead and dying trees
only
there is still a very substantial screen
of trees between this house
and all the residences on the cops and
there is absolutely no intention
of removing any further trees as part of
this application
at sintar architects we regard design
and context with the highest priority
and i would like to think that the new
semi-detached houses next to the site on
high elm road
designed by us and with close
cooperation with the planning officers
involved
are a positive contribution to the area
this house refurbishment and extension
will be no different
the quality of the materials and design
will hopefully enhance the area
that's two new neighbors do i would like
to therefore reassure
all those who raise concerns due to the
size of the site
the distances involved protection of the
trees and retention of the screening
and the consideration of the design
features that there will be no loss of
privacy
no loss of visual immunity no loss of
trees
and once complete the neighbours and the
residents of the cops did not know it
was there when in their houses or
gardens
i would therefore ask the committee to
support the officer's recommendation to
grant this application
thank you
thank you miss coley um i'm looking for
members to open the debate
on this uh item remember members wishing
to speak
no okay well i'll open the debate um
i went to view on sunday and uh i really
don't have any
concerns about this the uh those
distances at the rear of the properties
um
are significant so i don't see any
effects on the on the extension to the
rear affecting
those neighbors at such a distance um
an important aspect of this is that no
more trees will be removed that would
that has been a concern i think from
from residents um trees have been
removed in the past there's a tree
preservation order
on the site now so no trees will be
removed uh
with this development and i did notice
that there was no objection
to the the neighbor immediately adjacent
to the property
and it's perhaps arguable that they
would be the most affected by this
application
and certainly they'll they'll know all
about it but but they've raised no
issues
so i'm i'm very happy with this uh
application but
let's see what everybody else thinks
about that um councillor jerome you'd
like to speak
thank you chair i i feel very much the
same as as you really i mean my first
concern what was the trees
i mean that they are a beautiful strip
of
or corridor of trees that go but go
behind the houses
of mature trees as well ones i think
which
this council would look unfavorably and
obviously have given tpos
um but i think the report adequately
addresses that issue
and we know that no further trees are
coming down and the ones that have come
down already
are due to kind of disease or decay so i
think that that was enough to satisfy me
on that and
i did go round to the cops and you can
see the building but it is actually
quite
far away from the houses on the cops so
for me i think i'm quite satisfied that
you know
this sits within our requirements and
it's a an application that i'd support
thank you thank you councillor jerome um
councillor proctor
thank you chair yeah i would tend to
agree with yourself and uh
councillor jerome on this um i think
it's um
a reasonable application i think it's a
good design actually good design
and i think the applicant has worked
quite hard to make it
acceptable to the residents so you know
a lot of good work has been done there
to make it um as good as can be expected
yeah i was concerned about the trees but
that's not a particularly significant
issue
um the objections were on well also
trees which i think is the non-issue
the privacy issue which as you know as
others have said
and not particularly um there's not
particularly large impact
um the street scene which i don't think
is going to be impacted either
so i think the you know the uh elements
have been
mentioned by the officers and the
officer report i would
agree with really and i would suggest
that we should agree
accept it um reasonable application
um good design
thank you councillor procter uh
councillor hartley
thank you chair i think other members
have covered most of the points that i i
wanted to raise the only additional
concern that i had until i until i went
to view to view the um
site was around the uh raising of the
roof height
which um you know can make a can make a
property look
out of place on the street scene and i
think raising the roof height
will make it a lot taller than the then
the immediate next-door neighborhood but
i think it's number 78 but looking at
the street scene
on that side of the road there are there
are houses that are over uh you know a
similar height with with higher um
higher ridge heights further along
so um i've no further concern so i'm
happy to
approve the officer recommendation on
this thank you
thank you counselor minis
thank you chair i'm just looking at this
and i don't
i can't see any um the objections that
there i can't see any concerns for the
the neighbors at the rear like
i pretty much agree with you there um
and
no more trees are coming down the ones
that came down came down for
for reasons and they've been protected
now i can't see a reason to
to object really um so yeah it seems
like a nice design
don't have any issues it's not going to
overlook on anybody
so yeah that's fine thank you thank you
councilmem
just on the high i guess those bungalows
are across the road
uh they have
a concert but there's a you know there's
a road in between
those properties and the application
site so i don't see that
that the raising of that height and
capsule hardly mentioned i don't see
that as being so significant
to warrant a refusal there's different
designs on
on that uh on that particular road it
hasn't actually been moved and seconded
that we grant this application
would somebody like to move that we
grant it
uh council of minutes is happy to move
that we grant it thank you councilman
anybody second it councillor proctor
thank you for that
removed and seconded that we grant this
application so i'm going to go through
the mo
the voting i'll i'll ask you
individually and
councillor dr bark has had some problems
with her connection so
i'm advised that she won't be able to
vote on this item
and so we'll go to councillor carey are
you for or against the refusal
i'm gonna vote to grant the application
please
thank you very much councillor hartley
thank you chair uh happy to uh vote to
grant
us per obviously recommendation thank
you thank you councillor jerome
thanks jim i'm also happy to support um
officer's recommendation to graham thank
you councillor morgan
he's not here he can't take his part of
course yeah um
councillor procter happy to agree the
officer recommendation to grant
thank you councillor rigby's not here
councillor wins
stanley uh thank you chair happy to
agree the officer's recommendation to
grant
thank you uh councillor thomas
uh happy to agree the recommendation to
grant
thank you councillor minis yeah i'm
happy to um
support the officer's recommendation
thank you thank you and i'll be
supporting
the officer's recommendations so that is
unanimous
sorry i didn't laurie sorry
last but not least councillor williams
yes noah support officer recommendation
to glenn thank you councillor williams
thank you
okay everybody that application has been
granted um
are we able to go back to the first item
miss carly uh i'll just check with
with with uh my officer that she's she's
available and also we need to get
councillor morgan back into the meeting
council absolutely
absolutely so we'll wait we'll wait for
that wait for that
oh councillor morgan is back with us um
sarah are you able to confirm whether
bethany's in or bethany are you
are you with us
it does appear that beth is with us but
she doesn't have microphone
um i'll just i'll keep i'll try and get
in contact with her stay with me okay
so may i suggest we do a three meal
milfield then
chairman yes yeah yeah that's fine
that's fine okay everybody we're going
to go to page
58. that's three millway hail barns
mr pearson's going to give us an
introduction to this item
and i'm going to step out of the meeting
and councillor williams
is going to take over and share the
meeting okay
thank you can everybody hear me
and can you see the screen in front of
you with the uh with a presentation on
it
um this application has been reported to
committee
at the discretion of the head of
planning and development now by way of
explanation
uh officers had implied to the objects
at eight castlework
that there was still an opportunity for
her to ask a counsellor to call in the
application to committee
unfortunately the calling deadline had
expired at the point the message was
given against this background council
walt who had himself been contacted by
the objector
thought the objects that should have
been specifically told by officers that
the calling period had expired
but it was no longer possible the
application to go to community by this
means
and as they were not the calling period
should be extended to enable councilwork
to call the application in council will
then call the application in and
although this request without a time
the head of planning and development
using herded correction
referred the application to the
committee
okay so i'll i'll move on to the
application now the the site plan there
you can see the application properly
here
two-story tap dwelling on the north side
of middleweight and the residential area
of hail barn
the application proposes the erection of
the first full side extension
above the encourage you can see there
so i'll put the proposed drawings on
there
you can see the front elevation here and
the rear elevation down towards
the bottom of the screen
um the application also proposes some
other sort of external work the
rendering of the property
these two new cable features re-roofing
modification of existing openings and
other operations
the key considerations in terms of the
assessment of the application
relate to design appearance and
the residential immunity impact for
neighboring properties
objections have been received from the
property one of the properties to the
rear number eight catalan
the property next door number five
millway and also from chemical
but notwithstanding that
officers consider that the application
will
be in the wider street scene from the
appearance and that it won't detract
from the character of the
area and in that respect the development
could be in accordance with policy l7 of
the core strategy and
spd4 and in terms of
impact on immediately as the extension
is only to the side of the existing
house
and does not project beyond the existing
rear elevation
there's not considered to be any
material increase in overlooking towards
neighboring properties
but that existing interface distance to
the rear between the properties would be
maintained
one or two of the sides i can typically
there um
the property has sort of in and out
driveway at the moment
one of those points will be closed off
just a single access point
and then there's some photographs of the
of the property here
as you can see on the screen now you can
see the
top left there that the front of the
property the one to the right that
neighboring property number five millway
and the top on the bottom of your screen
is the rear of the property the
extension's going to sit
above that um some more photographs
there
you can see the neighboring properties
to the rear here
great cattle way um that's the rear
elevation of the application
type from garden of eight cutaway
and then finally there's uh i've got a
google
aerial view there you can see the
application property here
the extension going over that part of
the existing
property map number eight
kept the way up there okay so
there we go thank you i'll stop bearing
this now but i can put it back if
anybody wants to
thank you uh mr pearson so you
understand it i think that there was
two speakers against the application and
one speaker
in favor of the application but
counselor book doesn't appear to be in
the meeting
um is that ms butler
i can see in the attendance
brilliant um yes you've got three
minutes to speak
shall i just start my statement can you
hear me
miss butler yes
yes and so you've got three minutes to
uh to speak and then if you went over
your time we'll knock
you out
my name is sarah butler and i am here
today to reluctantly
object to this application and to ask
you to address a key deficiency in this
design and quality
in that it gives no weight to my privacy
and current way of life
our house lies directly behind number
three millway and is the only house
affected by this development hence my
sole objection
the original houses on millway were
built off-center to those on castleway
presumably as best practice to protect
the very privacy and well-being of the
residents of castleway
which is being called into question here
a home is a place of refuge and solace
it is our most private space where we
can be our true selves
in this case however i fear that this is
about to change irreversibly for my
family
the proposed extension on three millway
will introduce a room just 18 meters
from my property
with a large window positioned directly
facing our bedroom window
this is a full-size direct view straight
into the most intimate private room in
the house and this is the issue i have
it will significantly overlook and look
into a primary habitable room
causing a significant reduction in
privacy our en-suite door opens into the
bedroom and directly onto the proposed
extension
which means all privacy is gone and i
already feel vulnerable
with three young children in our family
i also consider this to be a
safeguarding risk
with regards to point 23 of the planning
office's most recent report
he states that the bedroom window
planned at number three will be
positioned
slightly off-centre which is in effect
admitting
that the majority of that window will be
directly facing me
this is on due visual undue visual
intrusion and means my privacy and
security
as a citizen of this border will be
compromised
i believe this planning application
specifically contravenes several
sections of current traffic planning
policies
particularly the sustainable community
strategy which states that developments
must not prejudice the immunity of the
occupants of adjacent properties by
reason of overbearing
residential environments should be
inclusive and design should not
adversely impact the immunity of the
surrounding neighbours
the meeting housing means policy states
that adequate levels of privacy should
be provided
it is worth noting that this house is
currently on the market
and any new owner may not have been able
to visualize the issue with the proposed
bedroom
from the perspective of the property
itself something counselor but
pointed out to me it may be too that
they would have privacy concerns
i fully support people's aspirations to
improve their properties
i have no problem in principle with the
extension itself
and in this instance i hope a simple
compromise can be reached
i ask the committee to understand my
concerns about privacy
and simply request the homeowner to
change the layout
in fact just to change the window to a
frosted one and or to add screening
plants to maintain my privacy
a small change would make a huge
difference thank you
thank you ms butler and then um speaking
in favor of a
mr cabba
so you have three minutes mr cover if
you can
unmute and um read out any statements
everybody hear me uh thank you chair
um our client has lived around hail
barns for a long period of time
and is seeking to move within the area
with his young growing family of three
children
he became interested in number three
millway as it provided an opportunity
for him to move within the area
and alter the house to meet his modest
family requirements
the existing property number three
middleweight is a small building that
has fallen in disrepair over time
and is in need of refurbishing and
modernizing it is one of the smallest
properties along milway
the proposed claim to extend about the
garage offers a very modest extension by
any standards
and even with the extension the property
will remain very modest in size
during the design process we engage with
the case officer
to address objections raised by number
five millway and about eight casts away
number five millway raised an objection
based on the extension being dominant
and that they would suffer loss of light
we believe this is incorrect as the
proposed
extension is very modest in nature
number five millway will remain very
dominant of a number three millway
as it has a deeper footprint and a
higher ridge
with an imposing facade we however
engaged with the case officer and agreed
to lower the rate height
of the proposed extension with regard to
the loss of light
both properties have their back
guardians facing northeast
and given number five milo has a deeper
footprint
we believe there's no further impact the
new extension will have than is already
existing
number eight castleway raised an
objection based on laws of privacy
because of the julian balcony that had
been designed and submitted at the very
outset
we know that they also pointed out that
they had no desire to prevent
improvement of the property however the
proposal
in its current format at the time was
unacceptable to them
we engaged with the case officer and
amended the design to replace the july
balcony with a standard window
on this basis it is our view that the
reason of objection was addressed
factorially we also wish to point out
that the bedroom window does not worsen
an existing situation
as number three midway has bedroom
windows already facing the rear
the proposed extension does not project
beyond the rear wall of the existing
property
and none of the bedroom windows
including the new one has a direct view
to eight castleway
the satellites are all angled
it is also worth noting that the rear
extension at number eight
castleware projects a lot further out
into the rear garden
than majority of other properties and
this has brought their window close to
their rear garden this however should
not prevent properties such as number
three milwaukee carrying out modest
extensions
it is overview that we we have addressed
the queries
raised satisfactorily and we asked the
committee members
to view the application all memories of
the design and support
uh the recommendation by the officers
which aim to improve and modernize a
property
that has fallen into this repair over
time by erecting a very modest extension
for very young growing family we believe
this will add positively to the street
scene
thank you very much okay mr kappa um are
there any members
looking to open the discussion on this
application
no um i mean i i'll just offer
my comments as um a starting uh
contribution i mean read through the
application and also made a point of
looking on the planning portal at the
plans that have been uploaded and it did
seem to me that
the proposed um extension is um
consistent with designs in the local
area
that it's not overbearing and that
you know it's relatively modest given
the size of the plots around there
um i think that as mr cabba referred to
when when i uh read through the report
it did seem to me that the applicant's
been willing to engage with
um planners um to amend the application
in a way that they think would um try
and
mitigate against um loss of privacy i
think that
there was advice that the rear window on
the side extensions should be
reduced or into concerns about the
impact on eight castleway and i think
the application
applicant's taking that on board and
amended the plans accordingly so
um from my perspective i don't have a
problem approving this application but
very happy
to listen to other colleagues and i can
see that people have indicated so with
that um counselor
jerome if you want to speak uh thanks
vice chair
um i kind of agree with you uh
vice chair um i did go and look at it
myself
and i appreciate the concerns of um
sarah and i know people can feel that
their privacy is being
you know impinged upon when such
extensions do happen
um but lots of people do live in similar
circumstances where
windows face each other across gardens
um
and i think on the whole you just have
to
be a little bit accepting of that and i
know it can be difficult
but i don't think any planning
requirements are being
um done in inappropriately here
and that there's very little that we can
reject on this application at all so i'm
afraid i'm afraid i'll
be voting in favor of this uh thanks
chair
you councillor jerome uh councillor
minis as indicated
uh thank you vice chair um yeah i'm i'm
gonna say exactly the same as dan just
said that you know you can
uh there are window you know windows
often will face each other and you have
gardens at the back or
or similarly maybe a road in between you
and
another house and i i'm glad that
actually that the balcony was then take
the juliet balcony was taken
off because obviously that that um you
know and
it's really good that they've worked
together with the
the planning department and try to come
up with something that's actually more
acceptable um
i don't think there's much reason to
actually refuse the application so we'll
be in favor of it
but thank you very much thank you
councillor minis
um councillor dr barkley thank you chair
vice chair
um i don't understand the um opposer's
view i mean it's always really difficult
when you feel that
your privacy is being um potentially
breached but
we know that there's already some kind
of um crossover between the two the two
windows anyway but i don't understand
why the objector is upset but i think if
officers are satisfied that the
distances are good and that there will
be no
uh deterioration in what's already there
in terms of overlooking then
and i am happy to support the
application and i do feel that it will
be a really positive thing because the
property does look a bit tired
and is in need of some loving care so
it'd be really nice to see that
property upgraded so with an
understanding to the objective i will be
supporting the application thank you
chair vice chair
thank you counselor dr barkley
um the application has not yet i think
been
moved or seconded are any members happy
to
do so i think indicated in the chat is
that
counselor thomas is happy to move in
favor
and counselor jerome are you happy to
second
okay um the application has been moved
and
seconded we now move to a vote
um and run through you as i see you on
my screen rather than
uh councillor walsh's order
counsellor proctor if you can confirm
your vote
i agree with the officer's
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor proctor councillor
minis
yes i i support the officer's
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you council and minister
councillor jerome
they also support his recommendation to
grant thanks
you councillor jerome councillor carey
i'll vote to grant please vice chairman
thank you councillor carey councillor
thomas
uh in favor jeff thank you councillor
thomas councillor in stanley
uh thank you vice chair uh happy to vote
in
favor of obviously recommendation to
grant you council winston council
hartley
thank you uh happy to vote in in favor
of uh
granting the application thank you for
having councillor morgan
agree with officer recommendations to
grant vice chair
thank you councillor morgan councillor
dr barclay
thank you vice chair i support the
officer's recommendation to grant
thank you councillor dr barkley and then
myself i shall also vote
in favor of approving officer
recommendation to grant
and i believe that that is therefore
unanimously approved
um and if someone can invite counselor
walsh back into the meeting
do vice chairman bear with me
okay have we dealt with that item we
have yes thank you
clairman um and we are now ready to
um take the first item on the agenda
because uh
ms brown is now with us great thank you
very much
um
so if we uh if we go to page number one
that's um
unit one ultragum retail part george
rich's way altering him
and um we have an instruction from miss
brown
to this item miss brown
thank you can you hear me yes yes
sorry i i was i i've had i.t issues
this full planning application relates
to land and units at the altringham
retail park in broadhead
the proposal involves the extension
refurbishment and subdivision of the
existing home base unit
to provide a downsized unit and then the
provision of a new retail unit to be
used as a discount food store
and occupied by little additional works
include the reconfiguration of the car
park new landscaping
and boundary treatments and a new
vehicular egress
there is an additional information
report for this application
which covers a number of matters this
includes recent submissions made by the
applicant
comprising a briefing note a letter from
lidl
a number of standard responses from
residents in support of the proposal
and council's opinion in responding to
officers recommendations
however none of the submissions provide
the outstanding retail and highways
information
as referred to as being necessary to
address the recommended refusal reasons
also covered in the additional
information report are the further
letters of support and objection that
have been received by the council
and clarity that a proposal to reduce
george richards way down to a single
lane
has not been submitted the mppf
is clear that local planning authorities
should adopt a town center first
approach
when assessing applications for maintain
center uses
the application site is in an out of
center location
the focus of these discussions has been
in relation to the sequential test
and specifically the opportunity
afforded by the sequentially preferable
altair site
in reviewing the recent submissions
officer's views on how desegregation is
approached in this instance are
unchanged
and similarly in respect of the
availability and of the potential
suitability
of the old test site for a food store
use
necessary information to support the
applicant's position remains outstanding
this more central food store opportunity
should be delivered before the
applicants out of center development
the mppf is clear that where an
application fails to satisfy the
sequential test
it should be refused the proposal is
also contrary to development plan
policies s11 and w2 on this basis
on highways matters the focus of
concerns
held by both the local highways
authority and transport for greater
manchester
has been in relation to the proposed new
egress on george richards way
and the potential for an unacceptable
impact on highway safety
this is in view of the proximity to the
a56 junction
and the potential for vehicular conflict
as drivers make lane change maneuvers
again when having regard to recent
submissions officer's views are
unchanged
necessary information remains
outstanding and it is
incumbent on the applicant to adequately
demonstrate that no unacceptable highway
safety impact would occur where
development would have such an impact
the mppf directs that a proposal can be
refused
the application is also contrary to
development plan policy l4 on this basis
the impact on a designated heritage
asset the railway inn has been afforded
great weight
however it is concluded that the harm of
a less than substantial nature
would be outweighed by the public
benefits the proposed development
would deliver a number of important
benefits this includes investment in the
retail park
the protection and creation of jobs
brownfield land
maximization and focusing development in
sustainable locations
appropriate weight has been afforded to
these benefits by officers
however it is maintained that these
benefits do not outweigh the adverse
impacts arising including when having
regard to the development plan policy
conflict
and the mppf conflict there is no reason
to take a decision other than in
accordance with the development plan and
relevant guidance
it is considered refusal of the
application is recommended
and on two grounds thank you chair
thank you miss brown um
we've got two speakers against this side
or two speakers
speaking to this item do we have miss
collins
mr collins are you there thank you chair
thank you yeah you have three minutes
miss collins thank you
before i start i would like to say i'm
down as a neighbour
on the additional planning papers that
came through this afternoon
and i'm actually speaking on behalf of
austrian mumbai civic society
that's fine thank you my my um
statement was proceed at the end of the
additional planning papers so i've had
to
change my statement slightly so it's not
to um
duplicate um ultraman burglar civic
society support the recommendation for
refusal
on the sequential test um
one of our concerns is about
consultation and the named council t
is altering him town center business
forum which doesn't exist
there is the chamber of commerce the
town center partnership the neighborhood
business plan
ocean business improvement district and
the civic society so
no lack of organizations to consult and
the broad teas partnership which
regularly reviews planning wasn't
consulted either
the civic society is experienced in
supermarket plans for broadhead
having dealt with the asda morrison's
saga we are also protecting the affected
heritage assets
the railway pub with camera and the
listed canal
warehouse on behalf of the broadhead
partnership i chaired a meeting with
local residents and companies whose
heavy lorries were blocking narrow
residential streets
the greater manchester spatial
frameworks brownfield register
has a large area zoned for industrial
development in broadhead
which also has much new housing uh for
example stanford brook
and everything exits onto the already
congested a56
been contacted by residents close to the
retail park
who complain about the lack of
consultation
either being inadequate or non-existent
now i realize that the applicant has
tried to address this but as i say
i only got the additional papers in the
middle of the afternoon
so i couldn't go back to the residence
but i think
perhaps some residents haven't been
consulted and
other residents who are very close to
the site and
on huxley street feel that their needs
haven't been addressed
thank you thank you miss collins um
do we have mr easton
mr easton you're speaking favor of the
application
yes can you hear me yes thank you mr
eastern thank you very much
thank you chair i'm jonathan easton i'm
a planning barrister instructor on
behalf of the applicants this afternoon
thank you for the opportunity to speak
three minutes doesn't give me an
opportunity to go through everything
and so i'm reassured that uh the chair's
comments the beginning indicated that
you'll be looking at all the background
papers including presumably
the documentation that came in fairly
recently
looking at this scheme practically and
with good common sense
the applicants are proposing a retail
use on a purpose-built
retail park this really should be an
uncontroversial application
that the fact that around 100 letters of
support have been received
far outstripping the number of
objections is we say testament to this
the proposal brings with it compelling
benefits
so downsizing will enable home base to
continue trading from this location
and 50 in-store jobs will be protected
and home base
have confirmed as much in writing
little's operation itself will create
40 local job opportunities there'll be
around 100
construction jobs created locally to
which one can add
the various spin-off benefits to the
wider supply chain
the existing retail offer will be
preserved and enhanced
in a sustainable location there'll be
significant financial investment in this
part of the borough
and there will be as the uh presenting
officer indicated the reuse
of brownfield land now set against these
benefits
and i know that these benefits don't
seem to be disputed there are two
technical points but which come
primarily
from the council's private retail and
highways consultants and i'll deal with
them briefly in order
so far as the sequential test is
concerned that the council's consultants
have focused
exclusively on the altair site which is
a town center
location however in policy terms ante is
not available
little is contractually obliged to its
altair scheme which is a basket based
store
rather than a trolley-based offer
doesn't include a home base
either these two proposals are different
prospects aimed at different shoppers
and that really should be the end of the
matter in policy terms as i've indicated
altair
is not available in any event
uh one of the policy tests is that the
sequentially preferable site needs to be
available within a reasonable time
frame if planning permission is granted
for the little and home based scheme
today construction can start this year
and the little store could open for
business by late spring
2021 altair won't be available for
at least at least three or four years
if the applicants have to wait this long
then it could have very serious
ramifications for the future of the
home-based store
the council's consultants expect
flexibility the format and that's a fair
point
but one of the key drivers for this
proposal is to allow home base with its
50 jobs
to downsize and survive the downsize
home base will never to be played less
rent but only if another
operator such as lidl takes up the
balance
of the site so that is the scheme
that's before members a smaller home
base plus a little
um even the council's advisors don't
suggest
that altair is suitable for such a
proposal
so our very strong view supported by the
documentation and by the um
opinion of a very eminent planning qc
is that a refusal on this basis what i'm
afraid be misguided
and ignores the true nature of the
application before you
you should also note and this is an
important point that the office's report
concludes
that there will be no unacceptable
impact on any town center
in trafford as a consequence of this
proposal
so i turned to highways mr easton you've
actually run out of time
so if you just finish on that i issue of
highways and
uh and conclude your speech thank you
well okay well forgive me i've timed
this to three minutes to perfection but
anyway i'll carry on with the time
available
there's no tangible evidence uh that
there would be a problem
in highways terms i just very briefly
highlight this
the visibility display of 80 meters is
more than adequate for this location it
will be safe
the modeling shows there'll be no
particular delays at the junction
so there should be absolutely no reason
for drivers to exit when it's unsafe to
do so
the concern about weaving which is part
of the proposed reason for refusal
is only really relevant in circumstances
where there are higher speed roads
in a low speed situation such as here
there won't be
any unacceptable safety impacts i'll
just finish with this chair if you don't
mind very briefly
um you've only got to turn on the news
and read the papers at the moment to
know the country is in it
in for a bumpy economic ride this is
exactly the type of development
that members should be approving and so
we therefore commend the scheme to you
and strongly urge you to grant planning
permission
thank you very much indeed thank you mr
easton
uh would any members wish to speak to
this
application councillor carey
uh thank you chairman and i'll believe
that this
application is all about balance and
where the council believes
the balance and weight scales go um i'm
actually going to
ask tonight if we could not support the
officer's recommendation
to refuse but actually to grant this
application
and the main reasons being is this
balance and
i see that this creation of jobs
is extremely important in this
environment with boots on that site for
example
um recently announcing lots of cuts and
store closures just on the broadly
saturn thinking
also i used to live in ultra in 2008
when the old test scheme
uh was first starting to be talked about
and it's now 2020. and
a few buildings have been knocked down
and they've got a fence up and nothing
has happened since then
like these gentlemen just said this
could get up and running quite quickly
i totally understand the issue with the
road but i would actually
call please for this to be granted thank
you chairman
[Music]
thank you councillor carey councillor
jerome you wish to speak
i'll just uh go to my notes
um the on the sequential test the
the institute of place management of
indicated 25 factors that are key to
regenerating and
revitalizing town centers they've
amassed evidence over a decade
and one of the key factors that they
mentioned is the retail offer in the
town centre
they should have a good mix of
independent and chain shops and that's
why i think this sequential test is
in the mpf is so important in protecting
this growth
um and town centers are so important to
our well-being communities
so i think it's vital that the council
apply the mpf mppf
guidance on this and i accept traffic's
arguments in response to mppf
and paragraph 86 clearly laid out in the
report
um it is up to the applicant to prove
the case and and council officers and
clearly think clearly i think that
they've
that they've failed to do this um this
is a shame of course because there are
many merits in reconfiguring the home
base offer on this site but but we
must stick to the crucial this crucial
planning matter i believe
and on the egress access on
george rich's way and i know this site
very well as an ultra room councillor
and a temple resident so i i use it
often
um and it's very busy at weekends but
also during the week
and uh the crossroads in particular at
mcdonald's and audi can be very busy
um and pedestrians often have to wait a
long time in that crossing
and you'll often see pedestrians making
that making their own crossing
um right by where the egress is
from the carpet right side over to where
the where the egress would be
um so i think this this could cause real
danger
uh for pedestrians also pedestrians
using the pavement where the egress will
be
but also cyclists as well because cars
are
often to look looking to move fast on
these lanes and and out of
out of this uh estate
so i think we do need to be really
careful on this egress point here and i
do think it is dangerous
and i think again the council made some
really legitimate arguments about the
danger of
exiting cars and the possible likelihood
of collisions
and so i think we need to be really
cautious on that front and i i
do agree with the council on that point
um but also
um i was a bit upset that that there
isn't more kind of demonstrable
initiatives around cycling
infrastructure on the site um we are
told there'll be some
uh there's some existing uh cycle hoops
but we're also told there will be some
covered cycling uh provision um
but there is a there is a problem with
crime on this this estate and
many people have told me about their
bikes being nicked and i would like to
see there to be more covered cycling
and secure parking on the site
mentioned by the applicant but also for
them to have some safe
cycling routes in and out of the place
as
as well which which i don't think
they've
been provided and but also i'm a little
bit worried about
the car park itself and i think drivers
will always
look to the quickest exit to get out get
out of the the car park
and you may see if there's a queue on
where the mcdonald's is
car drivers might jump quickly round to
where the egress is
and you might have cars moving quickly
within the car park to decide which will
be the quickest
kind of exit route from the car park so
i i definitely think more thought needs
to be given to this
and for that reason i'm probably going
to um
support uh officer recommendation but
i'd still like to hear what others have
to say uh thanks chair
thank you councillor jerome councillor
williams
thank you uh chad um
when i saw the agenda for this meeting i
was a bit surprised if i'm being
entirely honest to see that
refusal was recommended for this
application and really having
read the report my thinking hasn't
changed
significantly and certainly i see to see
certainly i failed to see any really
significant grounds on which
refusal should be based i mean i
understand the argument that's been made
surrounding
the sequential test and the
prioritization of town center locations
but i i think when you dig into it
there's a lot more to that position than
we're really uh
considering ideally alter would have
been delivered by now
but the fact remains that work is barely
commenced on the site you know counselor
carey
talked about the fact that it initially
received approval back in 2008 i mean
i grew up in altering um and certainly
i can remember altair being talked about
as a concept
from as far back as when i was 14 years
of age
so i don't really um blame
the applicant if they have frankly
lost confidence in the deliverability
of the old site and i can understand why
they'd now be in a position
at looking at alternative locations to
base a store
um more generally the other thing i
would say on the sequential test is that
this committee itself just a few months
ago
approved a separate application for a
little supermarket
to be delivered uh and built on chester
road in stratford
despite the fact that that's not a town
center location
despite the fact that it's pretty much
opposite a tesco extra
superstar and despite the fact that it's
located
literally sandwiched in between an aldi
in stratford town centre and an aldi
in white city and so i think really
you know members can make their own
determination about the sequential test
but
personally i i think it's more
complicated than what we're seeing
uh reflected in the report but when
looking
more generally at the application and i
know that the other
ground that's referred to as traffic i
accept what's said about um
the egress and i'm i i thank councillor
jerome for his thoughts
on the issue of the egress and i'll
listen to what other members say
but i do think that there is
slightly confused thinking in the report
about the impact on traffic because
we see that there's um that the
assessment that's been provided says
that
and a quote from paragraph 53 of the
report that
it is concluded that the general
increase in traffic attributable to this
development could be absorbed by the
local highway network
and without giving rise to a significant
adverse or severe impact
and i think really i i don't
know whether or not with that in the
balance
i consider that an objection or a
refusal on the grounds of traffic
entirely makes sense to my mind i think
we see as well from the report that it's
acknowledged that there would be
adequate parking on the site i think we
see again from the report
that officers have of the mindset that
there will be less than substantial harm
to the heritage asset
on site i think we see in the report
that
the applicant has worked with the
planning department department to
negotiate
no net loss of trees on site and i think
when you
add into the mix of all of that that we
would see
40 new jobs being offered that we would
see
an increase in consumer choice and that
we would see a diversification of the
market offer for
ultra income to my mind on balance
i think actually i i'd be in favor of
approving the application
um that said you know i'm always
prepared to keep her
open mind and happy to listen to what
other members have to say in the
application thank you chad
i think he might still be on mute sure
sorry about that yeah councilor morgan
you'd like to speak
thank you chair um yeah i'm i'm going to
sound very repetitive in terms of but i
i really did appreciate counselor
williams and i'm going to agree with
what
what what he said um i read this
application and to be honest as a
alternative resident someone who lives
less than a mile from this development
actually was quite excited by it um and
i'm really really quite surprised by
offers of recommendations i'm gonna go
through some of the points and don't
worry about every single one but just
some of
my my thoughts so um there's
there's a discussion the impact on a
heritage asset
the railway pub is a fantastic heritage
site but it's not going to be made worse
by
the the this additional fact that
there's already
a um a entire
retail park behind it in fact if
anything this is going to improve it so
there's a discussion about landscaping i
think there's a real improvements in the
landscaping
um b m prevention parking there is an
issue
around parking at their end of the car
park and i agree with that but that is
not affected by this
this development if anything this part
of the car park is empty
and part of what i think is really
exciting is we're going to replace
empty tarmac and that end of the of the
development is empty
it never has a car park on it it's why
it's been used for
social distancing um um
uh queuing over the last few weeks and
there's somebody who has spent
a significant more time on diy and
gardening in the last couple of weeks
um i i have gone to this home base and
queued in those cars
and there has not been a car parked car
on it um
um if anything it's affected by some of
the fact that it's a lot busier down
that
end um but i yeah i just don't think
that is an issue
um and then we get on the sequential
test and i completely agree with what
councilor williams has said
there are children the old pair site is
not a comparable
um offer for a start and even if it was
there are children there sorry not
children there are there are adults now
who when the altair site was first
proposed hadn't started at school
have are now at university that is how
long and i mean i don't know if there's
a single shovel been put in the ground
over the altair site it's certainly
i can't see anything in the five year
five years i've lived in the borough
um and i really am amazed to see
asda and aldi claiming on the sequential
test when
an aldi has been proposed on that site
just recently
the asda has been it's been within the
last decade we've had
this the littles approved in stratford i
really do think that uh
to to ask a supermarket to wait
five years ten years how long are they
going to have to wait
um i i really do think is is
is wrong and i think we have to put this
in context to where we are we
we are probably going to have the
biggest economic hit this country has
seen in certainly any
any of our memories um to put at risk
few current jobs at home base and future
jobs at little
um to lose the last remaining diy store
and i we lost b and q and in south
trafford to lose the last remaining
um re stand normal retail store
and drive customers out to stockport
potentially
if not trafford park um i i really do
think is it
an absolute shame and to lose that
development
on something which to reply and and i
actually think this improves it
we're going to we're going to lose some
tarmac and we're going to actually have
something which
creates jobs creates business it's
actually i think this is an exciting
offer
the last point i want is on the egress i
i i don't personally share the
someone who um uses this i don't
personally share quite the
the fears of the traffic report but i i
i do appreciate it but i don't think
we can put reject this whole fantastic
application
on on that and um so i'm going to agree
with councillor
um kerry and i'm going to support
rejecting officer recommendations and
support this
proposal thank you chair
thank you councillor morgan um
councillor proctor you'd like to comment
yeah thanks chair it's incredibly
difficult application this one
um one of the hardest ones i think i've
i've seen what i've been on planning to
make a decision on
so i'm really torn on it um
i think it does make massive business
the the plans are proposing and you look
at the
the impact on the local economy on jobs
and it would be significantly a
significant benefit
to the area and the community so i think
you know
we would if they think very strongly if
we were going to
refuse this application there are a
number of sort of concerns we made which
i don't think are relevant which i think
on the um heritage asset site i think
you know
council morgans i think could address
that really
and i don't think that's of particular
significance
um noise impact i don't think is going
to be
any more significant than it is now so i
don't think that that is
we're leading to this balancing act on
the
preferential side and the point of
egress
um i wasn't sure on those
those issues but i think what council
williams and
council morgan said has made me think
again about that that
this could take a long long time before
it's actually resolved
so maybe what you know the council
offices said on this is
is not uh as significant as perhaps
i did think initially um
i am concerned about the point of egress
i think that is gonna
potentially be because some greater
safety issues within the the location
but is that significant enough to
us to reject the application i'm not so
sure
uh like others i think i want to listen
to what other members are going to say
but i i do continue to remain torn but
i'm i'm moving towards the
the position of grant wanted to grant
this application but i will listen to
what other councils are going to say
in the rest of the section
thank you chair okay thank you
councillor procter councillor thomas
thank you chair uh most of what what i
was going to say was been taken by
council carries williams and morgan
uh i i don't see any form of issue with
uh granting this and i also believe
briefly that even the egress will slow
down the traffic from
the lights at the crossroads to the a56
and as long as you get the sequence
incorrect it shouldn't cause a problem
so i'm of the mind similar to
councillors kerry williams and morgan to
reject the recommendation and support
this
okay thank you councillor thomas
councillor hartley
[Music]
uh thank you chair yeah i i'm i'm a bit
torn on this one i think um
you know councillor williams um put a
case forward very well actually for
for um approving the application and uh
going against the office of
recommendation
i do still have some concerns i mean i'd
like to hear what other
other members uh other members say
um i think you know obviously the
the the economic arguments that we've
heard a lot of people mention
weigh way heavy on us particularly at
this time but we do need to make this
decision
based on planning law and planning
policy and planning guidance
um i have some concerns about the the
egress
um i i don't i don't really know whether
it's whether it's safe or not and i do
think we need to be guarded to a large
extent by the
by the you know the expert uh
submissions on that
and both um you know the local highway
authority and tfgm have
raised concerns about that so it would
be a much more attractive application if
that if that had been addressed and
and resolved i mean from a lay point of
view i've i've
i've never understood why there isn't
vehicle access at that park of
of uh of of broad east realtor park it
does you do seem to converge on that
mini roundabout and it and it feels a
bit frantic and there are and there are
tailbacks
there um so i understand what council
thomas is saying it could it could slow
the traffic
um but uh you know i also have concerns
about what councillor jerome said the
the pedestrian access and the you know
the access for cyclists to
to that retail park is is awful um this
doesn't do anything to
to improve that but that isn't
necessarily the applicant's
responsibility obviously
i don't have any concerns about the the
heritage uh
impact i think uh councillor morgan
summed up really well you know any any
damage to
to that here is his asset has has
already been being done when when the
part was built in the first place in in
my view
so that i think the main the main point
that does that concerns me is the
sequential test in the
mppf and i you know i'm very strongly in
favor of
of promoting our tone centers as the as
the
you know preferential location um
for shops and and i think you know where
i am is that i don't
i i don't know if the alternative site
in altair is is
is is comparable to be honest i i have a
lot of sympathy with what the
officer says in the report that the two
sites don't need to be exactly
comparable it's about broad comparisons
and
you know the fact the car park might not
be level access you know the fact that
it's
you know more of a metropolitan feel i
think still allows it to be broadly
comparable
and i think increasingly we'll we'll
we'll
we'll probably have to move to that sort
of mode of supermarket shopping with a
lot more
uh term-based shopping and you know
there's less traffic
uh less impact from that that's the sort
of model you see in a lot of european
countries it's a much more sustainable
model
um and i think i suppose it's
disappointing that
uh it feels like there's been a lack of
candor from the applicant about
what the arrangements are for that site
at altair
i fully accept that alter has been many
many
years in the in the making and uh you
know i've lived in the area since
1999 and i think it was being talked
about then
um but it but it does feel like there's
you know there's a there's a contract
being signed for little to take space in
that development and
we haven't had full candor about what
the details of that of that space
might look like which would allow us to
make a better comparison i suppose
um i suppose the other concerns i have
about how we apply that sequential test
is what is what counselor williams said
about you know little stores
uh and all these stores that have been
approved elsewhere in the borough
and i know in the in the briefing the
latest briefing that the applicant
sent out uh by email and by hardcopy
there is reference to the um to the new
oldie site on on
the atlantic way and so that that
sort of troubles me as well i i was i
don't think i was on the committee when
that application
uh was was approved um but
it you know it troubles me that we've
approved an out-of-town
site there for for all day it might be a
different size of site might not be
comparable
but uh you know i'm left wondering how
did we apply the sequential test
to to that site as well and uh
i know we have to consider each
application individually
on its merits but i do think it's
probably incumbent upon us to apply that
sequential
test in a consistent way and we either
say
we'll we'll stick to it quite strictly
and we won't allow
developments like this or we have some
you know we have some flexibility
and we will but i do think we've got to
do that in a consistent way
um so so i do still have reservations
about it
uh so at the moment i'm thinking that we
should reluctantly
approve the application but i'll listen
to what other members have got to say i
think chair
thank you
we've got all the speakers waiting to
come in but before we do that um
miss cole is going to give us some
information miss coley
[Music]
thank you thank you chairman uh i just
um think we need to
do need to clarify the point on them on
the old
oldie scheme because it is quite
different um and uh
ms brown might might wish to add to what
i say because she was the case officer
for that application
um the original consent for the retail
park included
a food retail unit that was the one that
was previously
um sorry still is occupied by
by aldi they got permission to switch
across to another unit um
at uh in in the retail park because
there was no
uh net or certainly a negligible
increase in retail
uh open a1 retail floor space
there's no need for a sequential test um
because it was it was a simply a switch
a
switch of units from a historic
permission
so it's completely different i think we
also need to make the point on stratford
and little from
we're losing you there rebecca can you
just go back and repeat what you just
said
we've lost you there for a moment um how
far back
um did you did you hear the point about
the that aldi was effectively a swap
yeah just if you if you just talk to
that again please rebecca okay
so the aldi the oldie on the retail park
was a a swap so the original application
for the retail park
included a food store as part of that
wider office obviously that would have
been
tested against policies at that time
and the point about the sequential test
is
is there may may or may not be a
suitable or available site
at the time of a planning application
and that could change within six months
so you can't reasonably say just because
oldie got was a food
food store allowed originally in the in
the retail park permission which is way
back in 1995 that
that um we shouldn't be applying the
sequential test now
so the up but the more recent older
permission was just a straight swap
so no no sequential test was required
also could do with mentioning lidl at
stratford we're looking at a completely
different catchment
and a completely different sequential
test because we're testing that against
stratford town center and against the
district the district center at seymour
grove
no suitable or available site was was
found
there was not in that catchment so
altering him
and the availability of altair it was
not relevant
to that particular application so we
cannot reasonably
com compare that um hear what members
are saying but we just need to
the the sequential test is a matter of
both policy and its
interpretation is a master of law so if
members
are um are going down this route that
we just we need to make sure that we do
so lawfully thank you
thank you miss corley um councillor
stanley you've been waiting very
patiently
uh thank you chair um it is the
sequential test which swings this for me
because all the
um all the direct travel we've got in
trafford now
is about regeneration of town centres
and encouraging people to not use their
cars
to to go shopping and
particularly if there's another site
available as there is in this case
then we shouldn't be allowing um
uh supermarkets and other shops to take
the the less advantageous advantages to
our worldwide plans position
if that expressed that well there's also
the fact that do we need do we need
the supermarket in the borough at all or
do we need another supermarket
in this particular location
and i would argue particularly with the
sequential test on the second of those
is that this is the wrong location for
another supermarket
and then when you factor in all the
issues around the existing traffic
problems of that site
then i am at this point
minded to go along with the office
recommendation to re
refuse the application i think it's the
wrong sort of development
and it will generate more traffic it
will go against our
um our stated worldwide plans
and it fails the sequential test thank
you chair
thank you council win stanley councillor
minis
thank you chair so i've been quite torn
so this is why i was trying to listen i
wanted to listen to the debate
actually um before i met came to a
conclusion and i've
wavered effectively either way so
um i do i'm not concerned about the
heritage asset because i think that's
been
gone a long time ago um with the railway
and i think that's just how it is now um
i'm not concerned about how the impact
of the part that's near
uh the development that's near wash
railroad and loss of car park because
that car park is pretty damned empty
my two major concerns are the um
the little road coming in we call the
egress thing uh coming in and
how on earth people are gonna cross that
road because i know when i've gone down
there with my bike
or walking as a template resident it's a
total nightmare
um so the only safe way of going is
driving which we're trying to remove
and reduce um so
my biggest concerns are
and that whether you need another little
or not
i don't think you need another super i'm
not a little sorry another another
supermarket i don't think you need one
i wouldn't have an issue per se with it
if that the highways part was resolved i
get why the egress is there to try and
reduce
the little tiny round about having to
cope with it all but
i think it causes another safety problem
actually crossing and
being person that lives near here i i
don't think that it's okay to have that
little road
and i don't think you especially need
another supermarket although i don't
have a problem with having another one
because while you go shopping
effectively in
home base you might pick up a few bits
in little so i don't have a
problem with that but i think i'm not
i'm not saying we
i don't feel a great need for it and get
that the road is the part that that
massively concerns me over
many of the other i think that's my
major sticking point
um i don't know whether we can have some
form of
um can it go back to a drawing board
because i do think with the current
client current climate
um i do think that i would like home
base
home base needs to shrink i appreciate
that and for it to be able to survive
um and for its longevity i don't want to
lose another diy store
in the in the area but i don't know if
there's a way around
the the little road i don't know if
there's a another
solution and if there was another
solution i would be i would happy be
happy for it to go back to the drawing
board and come back
with something that's more suitable and
preferably a way that we can incur you
know have a safer way of cycling in
safe way of walking in i think that's
the way we need to
um move really so just producing another
a little road which causes issues to
cycling and walking
is isn't isn't the way we should be
going but i would like to see
if that can be resolved then i would be
in favor i think without that in
resolved i think i'm i'm still going to
go in there
go go towards the officer recommendation
to refuse
thank you thank you councillor minis um
councillor jerome wanted to come back in
briefly councillor jerome thanks jen i
just wanted to make two points really
and i want to address the council of
minister's point
is with the lidl there will be extra
traffic
um the nature of a supermarket it does
pull in
lots of people um on a regular basis
so there will be extra parking but i
just wanted to
touch on the egress again because at one
point i didn't mention i went to look at
it
to today um look at the site
and there is an upslope quite a
considerable upslope
and i believe for many drivers
especially new drivers
they will be stalling there they
and many of them will be pushing off at
quite a speed to
go out and move into their gap and i do
think that egress
is a danger and one of the things that
worries me is is would be
accepting an application and putting
something dangerous in place
which could cause accidents and i i do
agree with council minister
i think this that needs to be addressed
just on its own
before i could approve this application
so
i just wanted to make that point thanks
jeff okay um
we've had a lot of comment about about
the highways about that egress i'm going
to ask
um jeff to come in and just speak to
this jeff are you there
i am counsellor yes yeah do you just
comment on the highways
issues raised by council and minister
councillor jerome and indeed other
members
okay thank you um yes in terms of the
the egress
um we've raised a concern around
the highway safety matters as identified
in the report
we haven't necessarily looked at
the what you do recognize that by
introducing the egress there will be
possible issues around pedestrians and
it
will impact on on the movement through
there and clearly the gradient will be
at an acceptable gradient but he
obviously will be steeper there
so as part of the egress we've we've
said that we have concerns by the
introduction of that
and and the movements on the george
richards way currently
there could potentially be um problems
with vehicles
changing lanes and moving through there
and could increase um the potential
accidents
in that location so that's that's where
we are with
with the egress we have asked the
applicant
several times to consider
the egress in a little bit more detail
and
also do some modeling around any changes
they may want to do
but i understand and i believe they've
repeatedly refused to do any further
work
okay thanks for that um councilwoman
thomas has got a question councillor
thomas
thanks chad excuse me um it's regarding
sequential
uh the altair site from what was in the
pack and what was said by the solicitor
for the application my understanding
from what i've read and what i've heard
is that little have already committed
to utilizing
the altair site for a smaller
basket-based store as he puts it
and therefore the availability of an
alternative site
in regards to this application to me
seems
like it's null and void because there's
already
something going there to offset that
availability
i just want to clarify in my mind that
i'm
reading that correctly please sir
would an officer like to comment on the
council of thomas's question
uh miss coley or miss brown yes i can do
chairman yeah um the the
the point is this isn't it's a matter of
policy principle so
um if even if both sites were to come
forward
and uh we have no reason to believe that
that uh
little would not um build both sites if
they had the opportunity to
the policy requires the town center site
to come forward first
so if there is that intention then that
that scheme
should be delivered first in terms of
the
um the nature of that site um
the the reason we we have ceased
negotiations is because
we have said to to the applicant well if
it is going to be a basket-based store
and it is going to be different
to um the offer here prove it show us
the plan
and that's what that's the information
that we have not been given
okay i've got no other speakers i'm just
going to make
some brief comments myself um
about uh people ringing me and sending
me letters
over over many months about this
application and uh
what i've insisted i won't insist it but
what i've suggested to everybody is that
everybody sits down together
and talks about it and sorts out the
issues it's a complicated application
and and that they work together to get a
consensus
now um that the the applicant
i have to say it appears to me hasn't
done that the officers are still waiting
for information it's outstanding
information that hasn't been supplied
to our planning officers and that that
really disappoints me
um i'm presuming people contacted the
chair of the planning committee in good
faith
but um they've basically gone away and
and ignored what i've said
so so that does disappoint me having
said that
i think the main issue here is is about
the town centre
and uh an nppf that's the national
policy framework
that governs the whole the country and
our own policies say
that sound centers must come first and
it's councillor when stanley
was saying that that's what we're about
we're about promoting our town centers
and i don't think
if we were to grant this application
would we would be promoting our town
center
i do i am disappointed the altair site
has been talked about all the time i've
been on the planning committee which is
over 20 years
and i share everybody's disappointment
but that site is there
and um and i think uh that is a more
suitable location
to this side um
and and for that reason i'm going to be
voting with the officer's recommendation
to refuse this application i think
in the heart of hearts the town centre
must come first
um i'm advised that the highways issue
are of a less of importance um i don't
think councillor menace
and uh and councillor jerome would would
agree with that that that is a busy busy
highway the a56 and uh and drivers
i have to say we'll try and find the
quickest way
off that site and they'll go into uh the
proposed little site and try to use that
egress they would do that but
it's surprising what drivers will do um
but we're not here to to
legislate for poor driving i don't think
it makes sense i went down
there on sunday and i don't think it was
so difficult
to visit uh home base and then come back
and drive back to the the the original
if i call it roundabout
and and exit the site from there i don't
see that as a big problem
um for anybody using that site so i i i
i've
i've gone away from the idea that that
we really need that egress
so so so to was to grant it and and
provide that egress that that does
concern me
but as i say i'm advised that the most
important issues that
that sequential test and we do say every
every meeting
we looked for guidance from our
background papers mppf and our our local
plans
are what we use to make our decisions
and
that is quite clear that we need to take
the town center first so i'm going to be
voting in favor of the officer's
recommendation and
to refuse its applications for the
reasons set out in the report
now if i suspect a lot of people are
going to disagree with me
but um which is fine but um
to go against the officer recommendation
we do need solid grounds
for doing that um so we'll need a we
need a proposal and a second
of why we feel we can go against the
officer recommendation we'll go into
that in more detail
it's a very important item and i want to
make sure everybody
gets a chance to say what they feel and
ask any questions
uh as well so councillor morgan you
wanted to come and ask a question
councillor morgan
thank you chair um i'd just like to ask
um officers a question
um um i mean i've got my views views but
i i think
it's um miss carolee uh mentioned two
sites she mentioned
uh the aldi um and um
which is on the same site as well as the
little up the road in stratford
um but what she didn't mention and i
think this is a very fair question is
the asda
which is less than five years old so in
the time that
um i've lived in this borough there has
been an aster opened
and that the altair site i mean we've
all talked about the ultimate site it's
been here for decades so why was the
sequential test not in
not not applied for the asda site
thank you um i'm going to
and this is possibly not going to come
as of a surprise to you
um david uh mr pearson um
was um the in my
in my position at the time of that asda
application and probably recalls why
um the detail of that so i am going to
ask him if he could explain that from
his from his knowledge
um i don't think he's he was necessarily
expecting that question but
certainly can answer it better than i
can thank you
yeah thank you mrs certainly wasn't
expecting that question and obviously
that's a long time ago and
can i remember well i wouldn't want to
you know state my life on this
i mean my recollection is that we we had
two applications
in um we had one on the b and q site and
one on the site in which
the the ld by the um answer was
subsequently built
and adopted because we recommended them
both the refusal
now the members ended up um approving
the hours to store now
i can't remember off the top of my head
just what those
reasons were i would we would have to
refer back to
with a note in a minute from that
meeting i'm afraid
okay that's your answer to your question
counselor morgan councillor williams
you'd like to comment
just just but just bear with me chairman
i think uh i think uh
miss brown has an answer on that because
i think she knows the history
yeah thank you chair i was just going to
say
that um obviously asda
is a a different operation at broad
heath
and would require a much larger site um
it's a in a fat food superstore with a
greater floor space requirement
than the little um so i would imagine
that the sequential test that was
applied in that case was looking at
a larger site um
and and just to clarify it was
the availability of altair of the
potential availability and suitability
of altair
for a food store use has only come to
light recently upon submission
of the application by little for the
proposal at broad heath
okay councillor williams you want to
come in
thank you chad um i just wanted to
clarify my own thinking
about um the sequential test because i'm
conscious that a lot of members
have uh referred to wanting to protect
and prioritize
our town center settings and our town
center retail offer
and as i understand it you know that's
what the sequential test is all about
i think what i wanted to highlight was
that my thinking is informed by
principally on this matter uh paragraph
43
of the committee report
and it says in that um paragraph that
whilst it is recognized that ultraman
town centre's vitality and viability is
more precarious than it was envisaged a
few months ago
and that's as a consequence of the
covered 19 novel coronavirus pandemic
it is not considered that the impacts
arising from the little food store
proposal would materially impact
on the trading position of its grocery
operators
and thus its vitality and viability
would not be undermined in a way
which could be assigned to the little
proposal so
i think that members need to be
conscious of the fact that the report
itself and i think that um
the speaker who spoke in favor of
the application the representative
acknowledged this and highlighted this
the report itself recognizes
that we're little this little
application to be approved in
a broad heath retail park there would
not be an impact
on the vitality or viability of
ulcering and town center i i don't
dispute that i agree with that
assessment
so i just wanted to clarify that
thinking my view remains
the same the benefits of this proposal
outweigh the negatives and these
applications
when they are complicated when there's a
lot in the mix they're always about
a judgement of balance and i think on
balance this application
remains one that has more benefits than
negative signature
thank you um
counselor jerome did you want to come
back in are you happy with the answer
you've got from miss coley
yeah i'm happy thank you right um
do any offers want to comment on
councillor williams point because it
does seem to be uh
um saying one thing in part of the
report and saying another thing in
in another part of the report anybody
wish to comment on that
i i think i think the point of the
sequential test is
is that it is a different test to the
impact test now the impact test might
have been passed here
in that there is no adverse impact
demonstrated on autonomous town centre
and the food uses
but the sequential test is to ensure
that the benefits
of retail development in town centres
accrue to that town centre
so if if the development takes place
elsewhere
the benefits of that such as enhanced
football league trips all that sort of
thing
wouldn't take place so you can't you you
are taking away a positive
rather than applying a negative
okay i hope everybody understands that
right so has it been proposed and
seconded that we
grant this application
so we need two members to uh give us
give us the reasons why we want to grant
this application
um if i may um chairman
um i would if if there was a proposal to
grant in order to ensure that that is
a lawful uh decision i would um
don't wish to lead members but i would
like to to explain the two
options that are available to them
so members can determine that there is
a suitable and available site at
altair that there is development plan
conflict and that there is
um mppf policy conflict and that that
policy conflict indicates that in these
circumstances an application should be
refused
and that they they understand that
however they think the economic and
other benefits
of the scheme outweigh
both the development plan and the
national planning policy framework the
other alternative
is that members and i have heard this
don't consider
altair to be a sequentially preferable
site because it is
neither suitable nor available or one of
those
um i think i think what i'm hearing is
that they don't believe it to be
available
in a reasonable period in which case
there is no sequentially preferable site
um
and that the retail and because the
retail impact
is acceptable there's no reason to
refuse on retail grounds
we would also need to deal with of
course the highways reason for refusal
again members could determine that they
don't consider the highway impacts to be
so significant that a refusal of
permission is
is warranted um any any
other means of looking at it does does
risk not being not being lawful but as i
say i'm not seeking to lead members
just to to advise them okay
but somebody will need to speak to speak
hi laurence i'm i'd be happy to propose
on the
um second of um um
what rebecca said i i don't i don't
believe it's the sequential given the
it's just not available um um um
they'll i mean we've always talked about
the altair site and i i think we've got
to
i think that is is the reasonable way to
do it but i'm
thank you rebecca sorry miss cowley for
um um
um coming up with some wording
okay chairman i'm happy to second that
and
thank you to mrs coley as well for
wording it a lot better than i could
thank you for that counselor carey um
are you happy with that
miss coley going forward
i am as long as uh other the other
members
who are minded to oppose the officer
recommendation are also content
um and i would also appreciate some
positive confirmation
from councillors morgan and carey that
that that
on the highways reason as well we need
we need a we need them to confirm their
their views on that
councillor kerry councillor morgan
commented
i'd be happy to come firm on that um i
think i shared my views earlier and so
yeah i'm happy with that
yeah okay
are all members comfortable with what's
been proposed by councillor morgan and
councillor carey
okay okay so on the voting do we need to
go
to the office's recommendation first or
do we need to go to the alternative
proposal first take the alternative
motion first please generally take the
alternative motion first okay
i'll i'm going to go through
individually people are they that
we're going to ask people if they're
going to go against the officer's
recommendation
and grant this application now
councillor dr barkley um
just remind me are you still able to
vote on this application no your
internet's had some
difficulty today chairman i lost um
about five minutes of
um listening time so sadly i can't vote
thank you
right okay thank you councillor dr
barclay um
councillor carey thank you chairman i'd
like
to vote against the offers
recommendation please and vote to grant
this scheme
thank you councillor hartley
thank you chair i i would like to um
stick with the officer recommendation so
i i would i have too many reservations
about the application
as is i think it i think it's
disappointing that
these issues haven't been resolved so i
would go with the officer's
recommendation and and vote to
refuse the application thank you
councillor jerome
yeah i'm the same as uh councillor
hartley um i support
the officer's recommendation okay
councillor morgan
will be against yes
against officer recommendations and
sports grant chair thank you councillor
morgan councillor procter
um with a high degree of reluctance
vote in favor of the office
recommendation to refuse
okay council win stanley
uh thank you sir quote in favor of the
officer's recommendation to
refuse thank you councillor thomas
thank you i vote against the officer's
recommendation to refuse thank you
councillor williams
mr uh vote against officer
recommendation to refuse
thank you council and minis
i'll be voting with the council with the
officer's recommendation to refuse so
against the
counter yeah yes yes that's fine thank
you councilman
and i'll be voting um in favor of the
officer's recommendation to refuse the
application
um you need to count those
if anybody else has count with them and
has recorded them they're very welcome
to help me out
um i get six votes um
sorry four votes for
councillor morgan's proposal to grant
the application and six votes
against councillor walsh so that
application
are we quite comfortable now we need to
take the
we need to take the other the other way
okay are we quite
quite comfortable with those numbers
yeah
everybody i get those same numbers
cancelled
yeah thank you for that mr pearson okay
we're gonna go with the uh
proposal from the officers now um
council win stanley is happy to propose
the application be refused i'll second
that the application be refused dr
barclay's
unable to vote councillor carey
i vote to go against the offenders
recommendation please thank you
councillor hartley thank you
i vote for the officer recommendation
thank you
council at your own recommendation to
refuse
you your favorite refusal because of
your own
favorite refusal counselor morgan
i'm uh oppose officer recommendations to
um
uh refuse this application chair you uh
councillor procter
or the officer a recommendation to
refuse
uh thank you chair boat for the
officer's recommendation to refuse
thank you councillor thomas
i vote against the officer's
recommendation to review
thank you councillor williams
uh vote against officer recommendation
to refuse that
thank you councillor minis
vote for the officer's recommendation to
refuse thank you
and i'll be voting for the officer's
recommendation to review so we're being
consistent
and it's six against four again
according to my calculations
so that application has been made
just to clarify on both reasons for
refusal
yeah yes
yeah i'm happy with the reasons cited in
the in the office's report
anybody got a conflicting view on that
who's voted for the officer's
recommendation does anybody think any
differently
no okay yes so um
that's been refused for the reason set
out in the report uh
the application has been refused okay
that comes to the end of our
planning applications we're gonna go to
agenda item
seven chairman chairman there's one more
please oh sorry
there's one more
oh sorry absolutely um sorry about that
everybody page 68
we're going to great hayes 74 bancor
lane
and we've got miss cole he's going to
give us an introduction miss coley
i am just there with me while i um
get the
slideshow for members thank you
um okay so this application relates to a
site on the southern side of bank hall
lane
occupied by a detached residential
property with a swimming pool and
a pond in the rear guard and you can see
it there on that um
on the aerial shot to the south of the
site is open countryside
and and this is within the greenbelt and
it also forms part of a protected
area of landscape character as a public
right of way along the western boundary
the grade two listed building um bank
hall
which is approximately 150 metres to the
west of the site
to the east of the site is a rectangular
piece of currently undeveloped
greenfield land
uh beyond which is the marydale which is
a cul-de-sac of detached residential
properties
the site's not in a conservation area it
doesn't join the south hale conservation
area to the north
it's here um the application
seeks permission for the erection of
three detached
uh two-story five-bedroom dwellings new
access would be created at the
northwestern corner you can see that
coming in here
see each of the three dwellings one two
three there
and the existing access which is around
here i think would be closed
and uh key issues for consideration on
this application
development design an impact on the
character appearance of the surrounding
landscape
impact on heritage assets residential
immunity highways impacts
trees ecology drainage so
these are the three houses that proposed
in in in more detail
see each of those i'll click through
those
third one to the landscaping plan the
site's previously been the subject of
applications for a care home development
and this culminating
public acquiring 2019 although the
current proposal is materially different
to the care home proposals the
inspector's decision is still a material
consideration
determination of this application the
recent resolution to grant outline
permission for a detached dwelling on
the site
directly adjoining the site to the east
is also relevant
proposal has been brought before the
committee following receipt of
objections from 18
separate addresses there have been no
objections in principle
from consulting subject to appropriate
conditions
the layout of the development has been
amended since it was originally
submitted
to take the retention of a mature oak
tree
on the site frontage and to include
ponds on site
um to mitigate for the loss of the
swimming pool
and the pond used by great crested newts
and also back mitigation measures so you
can see the oak tree is that is that one
there
and the mitigation ponds are these are
these down here in this corner of the
site
rose development will provide a net
increase of two new family homes
contributing to this housing land supply
short citing a sustainable location
is considered to be a well-designed
scheme which has an acceptable impact on
the adjacent area protected landscape
character
adjacent heritage assets and residential
immunity
greater manchester ecology unit have
been consulted on the application
raised no objection to the development
subjects the various ecological
mitigation measures proposed
including the translocation of great
crested news from the existing water
bodies
and the construction of replacement
habitats on flight for both crest
great crested mutes and bats these
mitigation measures have been secured by
condition
additionally a license will be required
from natural england for those works
which affect protected species
and which is a separate process from any
planning application
subject to conditions the application is
considered to be an appropriate form of
development
in accordance with the local development
plan and the mppf
therefore it's recommended that planning
permission should be granted
thank you i'll bring bring the screen
down but i can always bring it up with
members of
those during the proceedings thank you
thank you miss cauley
and we've got two speakers to this um
application
um speaker against it was mr lafley
and uh his statement was going to be
read out i think
um are you reading that statement out mr
cauley
no ms lowe's we'll we'll uh read that
statement
yeah thank you chairman
for the attention of councillors sitting
in the planning and development
committee dear chairman thank you
i have lived nearby the site of great
haze for more than 33 years and have
enjoyed the diversity the area holds
one month ago the committee approved
with the majority the recommendations
made by the trafford planning team
for allowing the development of a single
dwelling on the green
wildlife corridor immediately next to
the land of the application site you
will be called to vote
very shortly for the referred
application
you therefore have directly approved in
good faith that allowing one dwelling
was better than three not touching
anything of the vegetation on this
project was recognized as great
and the proposal to in too important
to build at 16.5 metres from the main
road
was a plus to consider at the time a
number of councillors expressed
reservations towards the application
saying if we allow one what will stop
more to be built down the same lane what
will refrain
people to apply to develop even more
fields in the south part
of bangkok lane between the lane the
ballen and the green belt
down to the playground and allowing this
abs application
there was an absence for consideration
for the wildlife and the green area of
bangkok lane
which all walkers and residents enjoy so
much
there the number of objections was well
over 80 as you will have read
now you have to consider this new
application next door to the one
mentioned
and you are fronted with your voting
choice which if you accept the
recommendation of traffic
planning you will have to turn your
jacket
inside out and swallow that three houses
is better than one
felling 16 trees is great to allow the
build to take place
and that getting very close to bank or
lane cannot be an issue
14 meters or about while the current
dwelling is to be
demolished is indeed further than 60
meters
please bear in mind that the total area
which can be built
is no more than the green field next
door without
with only one dwelling allowed it would
be wrong not to retain your attention
on the great crested mutes a protected
species living in great haze for years
mitigation plans are one thing and i
know that the proposal is to create two
little ponds down the land in an
area where nothing can be built the
issue is great crested newts have lived
in the existing ponds for many many
years
they have established their habitats
using the vegetations growing in and
around the pond
making two holes in the ground and
filling them with water will not be the
same ponds they have lived for many
years
that would be good only for goldfish
they have to prop it well they have
proper well-established puns
to have well sorry i'll start again to
have proper well-established puns takes
years and you have no certitude at this
point
that great crested newts will survive a
new environment
also no mention of the shade and sun
exposure required has been
analyzed or made this mitigation officer
is nothing more
than powder in the eyes of the readers
clear consistency in the recommendation
reports written by trafford planning is
seriously lacking
so please counselors when you make a
choice contradict your vote one month
ago and follow the recommendations of
trafford planning
or stand up for the residents and their
best interests you have been elected to
represent and to protect
please make your marks heard loudly and
reduce this project to one
dwelling only thank you daniel lafferty
thank you miss lowes um i'm going to
bring in
miss williams miss williams you want to
speak in favor of the application
yes thank you chair good evening
i'm emma williams the planning agent for
this application
and i'd like to thank the officers for
their hard work and recommendation for
approval
ph properties have taken great care to
sensitively design the proposals for
three new dwellings at the site
detailed pre-application discussions
with offices have resulted in a proposed
layout
design and density which is cohesive
with the character
of existing properties along bankhold
lane and within the wider locality
full consideration has been given to all
of the comments received from local
residents
which may be related to trees and
ecology this has led to post-submission
changes to the site layout
to retain the oak tree at the site
entrance and to establish new dedicated
wildlife ponds to the rear of the
property
the officers reports are comprehensive
and no objections are raised by any
internal or external consultees
including the council's
arboriculturalist heritage and highways
officers
and the greater manchester ecology unit
the proposals are acceptable in terms of
one the impact on the character of the
area
due consideration has been given to the
refused 2019 care home appeal
and the proposed scheme represents a
significant reduction in volume
floor space height and spread of
development when compared with the
previous care home proposal
offsets to the site boundaries requested
by officers have also been significantly
increased with 20 meter separation to
the southern rear boundary
and a minimum of 14 meters to the
eastern and western side boundaries
respectively
to design amenity the proposals
demonstrate exceptional design
material quality and offer a substantial
improvement over the existing buildings
on the site
appropriate separation distances have
been achieved across the site to the
satisfaction of your offices
thereby safeguarding the immunity and
privacy of the new dwellings
three no harm would be caused to the
significance of the listed building
or to the adjacent south hail
conservation area
four a high quality landscaping scheme
is proposed
which increases planting along all
boundaries of the site and particularly
along the western boundary are joining
the public right of way
five a safe vehicular access has been
designed which will be taken from bank
hall lane
and lastly the impact during
construction in terms of noise and air
quality
will not be detrimental to the local
environment and the construction method
statement is required by condition 19.
as con covered within the officers
report the circumstances on the adjacent
site where one dwelling was consented in
may 2020 and as mentioned in the
previous statement
is very different the application site
the adjacent site is a much smaller
and undeveloped site within a wildlife
corridor
the application site is a previously
developed site with a currently has a
dwelling on it
and has no such policy restrictions
finally the scheme will deliver a series
of benefits including the redevelopment
of a part brownfield site
housing delivery green infrastructure
and biodiversity enhancement and
economic benefits arising from the
construction and occupation of the new
dwellings
thank you very much for your time and i
respectfully request that you resolve to
grant full planning permission in line
with your office's recommendation
thank you miss williams um
miss coley have you got any further
information to share with us
uh no nothing to add to that thank you
chairman i just wanted i was wondering
about the uh mr lafley's comments about
the great crested newts and their
habitat
um do we feel we're uh doing doing them
justice
um i can certainly expand on that i i
i did attempt to cover some of that in
my in my introduction um
we have consulted the greater manchester
ecology unit on this application as we
would do where there was where there
was an impact on protected species
they're quite satisfied with the
mitigation measures proposed and that
um consider that the impact on protected
species would be would be
acceptable as a result of that that
includes um
the replacement of habitat and a number
of other measures and if members want to
see what they are specifically
um
if you look at page at paragraphs 123
124 of your reports
on page 94 and 95 um
there this this sets out the
um the great crested newt strategy
there um in terms of how exactly
they're going to do it in terms of
receptor area and translocation
exclusion fence around the construction
zone
and additional terrestrial habitat areas
so to compensation ponds uh two high
binocular and log piles
tussock grassland and a new native
species
um hedgerow so quite a quite an
extensive
uh list of mitigation there and equally
well
um that's there's mitigation for the for
the loss of the
sites in terms of more back boxes on
retained mature trees and three
integrated back
back boxes on the new residential
dwellings
so that's all covered uh it's also worth
noting that any works that affect
protected species will require
under a separate consent regime and
license from natural england
uh to carry out those works uh and and
that would focus on the impact
of of the works on protective species
and
ensure that that was not was not adverse
thank you chairman
thank you thank you for that miss coley
um councillor jerome you'd like to
comment
yeah obviously i i visited um this site
last time out on the planning committee
when we had a
development next door and it is
one of the most beautiful areas that
i've been to in the borough
you know i couldn't believe that i
hadn't been there before
and walking down that public right away
um
it is amazing and when i walked down
there first time
um the two well a tourney owl flew over
my head
which which which i later found out
actually nests on the great haze site
um and what i think is when you walk
down that public right away
you you can look into great haze at the
moment
and though there's a house there on the
whole it is fairly pleasant it's well
landscaped beautiful trees beautiful
garden
and it doesn't detract too much from
from walking down that site
but what what's going to going to
replace it i believe is a massive
over development and what if you look at
the plans it look it actually looks as
though there's a new road
in into that area of land with three
separate houses leading off it
and and if if you look at the parking
situation
on site there's each house i believe is
going to have double garage
garages as as well as a small driveway
which can fit two cars
so these houses could have two three
four cars
on each every one of them with 12 cars
passing up and down and out of
this area of land so when you walk down
that private
um access lane in future
you could see a well over developed site
lots of cars coming in and out
um and i i believe that will have a
serious
effect on any any attempts at mitigation
of of the nature that's currently on
site
so you've got the tawny owls as i said
you you've got the
the pipistrelles and the soprano bats
you've got the great crested newts
that there may be attempts to move them
to a different location
but that may not be successful um and i
think that's
noted in the mitigation attempts that
these plans to move animals
like like this quite a fragile
ecosystem is difficult and they may not
be successful so we may lose those
animals and further kind of
impinge upon this wildlife corridor um
which i i think would be tragic
um so i i can't see myself
supporting this application which will
strip out
many of the trees that have grown there
over time
which are mainly native varieties and
you know it that will take a good 10
years to represent properly
so i think this application is a
tremendous over development of the site
i think it would you know the street
scene will be affected
and uh you know i can't i can't find
myself supporting this application
at all but i'll be interested to hear
what uh other people have to say
of course okay thank you councillor
jerome councillor williams
thank you chad again and i appreciate
what councillor
jerome has just said but i have to say i
take a slightly different
um perspective because i think like
youtube
i'm aware of um the previous uh planning
applications that
have come within the vicinity of this
site and i think a massive over
development of the site would be a huge
care home which was rightly in my
opinion rejected
by the committee previously i think
you know one balance um the brother does
not have a five-year
supply of housing i think there is a
need for housing
in trafford and um i have to say i
i looked at the plans and
you know i take on board what counselor
jerome said but i just i reach a
different conclusion that i don't think
it is an over development of the site so
i i have just actually personally
i i'm in favor of the application and i
appreciate everything that mrs coley has
said
um in respect of the uh great crested
news and
um consequently i'm happy to move that
we
approved this application this afternoon
thank you chad
thank you councillor dr barclay uh thank
you chairman
and um i i also feel that
um we should be supporting the
application of following kind of
following on from councillor williams
i mean i understand councillor jerome's
concerns about the wildlife and needing
to find alternative sites if this is
built but that would be the same with
any development at this site any
any building work that took part that
took place on this unless it was
to kind of replicate the exact same
configuration i think you're at risk of
that with this site
and i think we're also very very
fortunate that we've already had an
appeal about the care home on this site
and the judge has given very very clear
guidance as to what he would find
acceptable and i do feel
the officers and the applicant have
worked really really hard
to make sure that they cover all of
those concerns and i think it is
a really sound report that has taken all
of those initial concerns on the
previous application
into account and i do think it's a big
site i don't think it would be over
development we do need houses within the
area
and my only little concern is yes there
could be a lot of extra cars and that is
a difficult road
to go up and down but i don't think
we're talking about anything
particularly significant
so and with all of that being said i
will be happy to support officer's
recommendation
thank you thank you councillor dr
barclay
um councillor morgan
thank you cher um i mean i i was against
the previous the application
next door i wasn't on the committee when
the care home was proposed i don't think
this application is as bad as either of
those
but i i will not be supporting this
tonight um
um i know our prime minister has talked
about newt stopping
uh planning applications but i actually
do you think it's a real issue and i do
think the ecology impacts on
on this and i just think that the
re-housing is not necessarily
the way to the way to progress this as
well as the other impacts on
why i agree with council jerome i i am i
think it's a fantastic part of the
borough an absolute amazing
um area and i think it was raised early
by one of the officers in the previous
application what this
the the this borough is this part of the
borough has is massive houses
so why are we having three hit three
application three houses i would support
having
and one house but i honestly think this
is a real over development of the of it
and the council williams mentioned the
the lack of housing that we have
we're all aware of in this borough but i
honestly think when we say there's a
housing shortage we're not talking about
the site
these type of houses um this is not
going to impact when we have people
struggling to be able to get on the
housing ladder
and we're talking multi-million pound
houses here um
and i really do think and i do think
it's just worth the committee
realizing the reason that um there's one
a house built in the last one of the
reasons
was bangkok lane it is actually really
dangerous this is going to be on the
corner
a really dangerous tight band um
cars race up and down here um between
hale
barnes village and hale village um and
i just really do think this is an
absolute over development um
and so i won't be supporting officer
recommendations thank you
thank you councillor morgan councillor
hartley
uh thank you chair i i'm happy to uh
support the
the officer recommendation to grant the
application with conditions
um and i think like uh like councillor
dr barclay
uh i think the officer's report is is
good i think it should be commended it's
it's uh
you know brought in relevant information
from uh
previous applications for the site and
and the site next door
um it addresses the the ecological
issues i think with with the conditions
that
are proposed and you know the ecology
unit are happy with it
it it is a lovely part of the bureau
there's you know i i agree with that
um but there's a house there at the
moment so that you know the
the site has already been developed uh
it's um i think the report describes
that current house is quite a sprawling
development
which it is so i think in a lot of ways
in terms of the
the landscaping i think i think it may
well be improved by having this this
development there
um i think the design of the houses is
good i think the design of them is
you know is quite striking um i
i you know i don't accept what the uh
what the objector
uh said this is a a slightly bigger site
than
next door and it's a site that's already
that's already been
uh developed developed for housing um
i think uh people have mentioned the
road i think you know having the
new access uh road that's proposed if
you found where it is which is near the
public right-of-way
you can see both ways uh down um then
bank holder and very clearly so i
actually don't have any concerns about
about the road safety as a result of
this
uh of this development um the only real
reservation i have is
is the sort of gates at the entrance to
the drive and then gates at the entrance
to each to each house
um which i don't particularly like but
that is in common with with all those
houses in the area which you know
obviously are big expensive houses
so i i can't see a a a valid planning
reason to to refuse this application
so um so i'll be voting with the officer
recommendation chair
thank you thank you councillor hartley
uh councillor minis
thank you chair um having looked at it i
i
consider it um an over development of
the area because
of the what what you've got then you're
going to destroy a lot of habitats
of various animals i think that the
benefit as it were to uh you know the
benefit to the population put to people
around there
i'd say i'm afraid and these aren't
affordable homes
i think we all know that and it's not
really actually contributing to the
housing shortage
and and if you wanted to do that you
build a block of flats and you're not
going to build a block that's there so
i think that's a bit of a moot point and
i think that the
the um harm it causes to yes
they're not humans they are other
animals i don't think is uh
it's not i don't think it's okay to do
that
to be able to build a couple more house
you know a few more houses there i don't
think that's really fair
um i'll be voting against down to
ecological reasons
um i don't think that the benefit
outweighs
the harm it causes so my will be going
the other
going against thank you okay um
so if there's an is there an alternative
motion though that would be
a motion from the officers to grant this
application council and ministers talked
about going against the officers and
councillor jerome have
do you want to move in second that we
refuse this application you
happy to move thank you councillor minis
councillor jerome are you happy to
second that
yeah okay so let's take that first
all those in favor chairman chairman we
need a reason we need
i heard council administers reason three
on on ecology
um is does councillor jerome share that
that reasoning we do need to understand
what that reason is before going
i'm sure he does counsel jerome yeah so
for me i
i think the street scene would would be
um
applicable here also over development of
the site
um also the traffic issues the highway
issues
as councillor morgan said um
but also the mitigation of the ecology
will be
affected anyway by the extra lighting
and the
from the housing if you look at where
the houses sit they sit
almost entirely within the site and the
lighting from those houses
will affect all the ecology in the area
if it was just one house
the lighting does no wooden stretches as
far as it
it would do especially if you look at
the house currently on the site
so i think the mitigation attempts may
fail due to the
the size and the area of the houses that
they sit on and the lighting from those
houses
and that they're quite fragile creatures
so that would be another reason for me
if you can
i don't know how you pitch that in
planning terms but uh
okay miss coley are you happy with those
reasons
um i've i've i've heard enough i've
given the previous application for on
the care home
where neither ecology nor
highways was a reason for refusal nor
was picked up by the inspector as being
an issue
i would just say to members that those
reasons
are a bit thin uh and there's no
particular technical in fact there is no
technical evidence to support them
um and that i don't think they would be
held up at appeal
but leave it there thank you sorry
miss cowardly sir can i jump in because
um sorry laurence
um i i mean my my main one is it's over
development
um um i think for me the ecology and the
transport is additional to that but i do
and i've missed out who's probably got
strong
views on how how that can be written
um the over development one is a matter
of is is far more a matter of applying
judgment than it is a technical
so if if members are minded to refuse
the application i would recommend that
that's the that's the path they take
we we would we would be at risk of an
awarded cost on an ecology reason for
refusal here and a highways one
um and just say i'm happy that if you
want to put down as a being
over development that is absolutely
acceptable thank you
thank you councillor jerome you're happy
with that
you're on your mute counsel at your own
i think i did actually yeah
right that's fine yeah thank you thank
you okay so we'll go
we'll go through everybody um councillor
dr barclay on the motion
to refuse this application for the
reasons set out
no i don't support the um suggestion of
refusal thank you okay thank you
councillor carey thank you chairman i
don't support
the motion for refusal thank you
councillor hartley
thank you chair um also against the
motion for refusal thank you thank you
councillor jerome um
yeah i support the proposal
yeah you're very faint counselor jerome
we've heard you but you are you are a
bit faint
councillor morgan that's okay you're
okay councillor morgan
support the motion to um um oppose this
um flying recommendation thank you
councillor procter
against the motion for refusal
thank you councillor stanley uh thank
you sir against
the motion to refuse thank you
councilwoman thomas
pikachu against the motion to refuse
thank you councillor williams
uh thank you chair vote against the
recommendation to refuse
thank you uh councilor minis
i'm for the ref the motion to refuse the
motion thank you
thank you and i'll be voting against the
motion to refuse this application so
that's been lost
and um more people against it than in
favor of your motion
so we need to go to the positive vote if
i can call it that
am i correct mr chairman please
yeah yeah okay so counselor doctor
exactly
the recommendation are you for or
against thank you chairman i support the
officer's recommendation
to um to approve thank you very much
councillor carey
thank you chairman and for the
recommendation thank you very much
councillor hartley
banker chair support the officer
recommendation thank you councillor
jerome
i'm going to vote against officer
recommendation
thank you councillor morgan
against officer recommendations to grant
chair you
councillor procter thank you chair in
favor of the
officer recommendation to grant thank
you um councillor stanley
uh thank you chair voting in favor of
the officer recommendation to grant
thank you councillor thomas thank you
chair i vote in favor of the
officer recommendation thank you
councillor williams
chair vote in favor of officer
recommendation
to you council and minis i'm voting
against the officer recommendation to
grant
you and i'll be voting in favor of the
officer officer recommendation
so the application has been carried the
application has been
been approved i think was a good
discussion on that thank you everybody
for your contributions um okay so
i think now we are going to go to agenda
item 7 unless somebody
tells me otherwise and so there's two
stopping up orders the first ones that
agenda and gender item seven at the
end of your um paper
documents and um
it's proposed stopping up of highway at
one mercury way in stratford
manchester m41 7bz that's just near the
trafford center
um jeff could you just give us a quick
uh
overview of this yes yeah um all it is
it's um it's since it's associated with
permission
previously granted for a drive-through
um restaurant off mercury way and the
two areas
of concern are part of from part of the
old
access into the site the former site
which are part of the adopted highway um
so
we're seeking or the applicant is
seeking to stop up
a small section of highway so that they
can
close off the current access is provide
a new one
into the restaurant and providing new
footwear across the front
okay um
i should know this but do we need to go
to a vote
i believe believe this you do charity we
do need
to seek your approval for or members
approval for the uh
stopping up order okay so i'm happy to
propose it i went to view on sunday
i think it's quite straightforward it's
uh beside the hotel there at um
near the trafford center at mercury
where it's fine um
i'll propose that we grant this
application or we support it
um we need a second anybody like to
second it
is second channel thank you councillor
williams it's been seconded um
do i need to go through everybody
individually to ask them
i have to yeah no one's telling me
otherwise yes you should
yes thank you claire thank you thank you
very much
okay apologies everybody okay counselor
doctor barclay are you in favor of this
stocking up
thank you chairman yes i have approved
the recommendation to stop it thank you
councillor kerry thank you chairman i'm
in favor
thank you chair uh also in favor of the
thanksgiving yeah
thank you councillor jerome yes i'm also
in favour chair
thank you councillor morgan in favor
chair
thank you councillor procter sir david
thank you councillor stanley uh thank
you chair in favour
thank you councillor thomas uh in favor
thank you
thank you councillor williams
thank you thank you very much uh
councillor minis
uh yes in favor thank you thank you and
i'm in favor so that is unanimous
uh we're happy to support that's
stopping up um
agenda item number eight is the bay
moulton
um at broady um mr
evanson could you give us an overview on
this
indeed thank you um yes it again it's
associated with
um previous planning permission it's
to stop up some irregular shaped um
parts of the adopted highway so that the
applicant can form
um a wall to enclose a garden area in
front of the building
and we've secured a footway so at this
present time
there's some bollards across the front
and site
um and we're seeking to improve the
highway so that we form a proper formed
up
um but wait in front of the year new
house of
new dwelling which it will be then
there's just to stop a couple of small
areas of
highway so that they can then close it
into their um
boundary area and form a new um
butt weight across the front thank you
for that
i'll give you that mr uh councillor
jerome rather did you want to
ask a question about this thanks chair
yeah um
i don't really have a problem with this
at all but um
many residents have come to me asking me
about the public notices
on on this um saying that they couldn't
understand them at all
um and they are kind of written in
planning speak
but also the public notices don't really
tell them anything
so they asked me several questions about
the plan
notices and um i was unable to answer
any of them looking at the notices of
myself
or looking at the map for instance would
the road
be um blocked at all how long would this
go on for
um and several other questions which
from just reading the public notice and
the material
on the planning website you just can't
answer
um which me seems to be um
a kind of contradiction in putting out a
public notice
at all so i just wondered what the the
opinion on that was
from the planning offices
come back to you if you like on that
particular point yeah in terms of the
notice we did get contacted by one of
the residents who spoke for a number of
people in that locality and it did raise
concerns
we we provided them with the information
fully it's a notice and a form of notice
which is done by the government office
and the applicant put the signs the post
the nose disease up on site
it's not something that the council
actually directly get involved with
so the notices and the form of the
notice and what goes on site is actually
done by the government office
and in terms of the information that is
about readily available and on the
notice
it gives you the contact addresses where
you can
see the notice and but i did address
that particular point to some concerned
residents
and unrest and made them assured them
that
the stopping up order doesn't suggest
that the road will be closed
um at any point in time um and i
wouldn't expect them to
even when they're actually undertaking
the highway where their works or the
highway works
you're on silent there counseling
sorry about that um thank you mr evanson
for that um
councillor morgan's got a question
thank you chair again i think it's like
um councillor jerome
um i'm not against this at all and
especially i'm hoping
some great plans um for the um for that
pub
or former pub um i just wanted to ask um
jeff
in terms of on a highways basis that
that bridge
as i'm calling shaw camps the drone is
aware as an altering counselor can be
pretty dangerous and i've seen some
horrendous photos of
cars hitting bollards and it's just kind
of
even if it's not closing are we
absolutely sure that we're not going to
make that
uh what is a difficult bridge to to
maneuver around
any more dangerous um thank you
mr robinson i i don't believe so because
the
in terms of the footwear we're putting
in we're actually
just going to follow the existing curb
area
line anyway so we're not actually making
it the road any
um councillor walsh did mention too as
this
this afternoon that this was some
concern so what we will look to do is to
reinstate the bollards
on the new newly formed footway and but
i don't believe that the proposal in
front of you
um either the application or the works
we propose
to create a footway will make it any
worse than what it currently is
okay councillor williams you'd like to
comment
thank you chad um i don't have any
particular comments about the stopping
afforder i just wanted to
uh formally propose that we approve the
order
but um lastly i would just like to
compliment councillor
jerome's comments about um the sort of
language that we use in our written
correspondence around
planning and these sorts of matters
because sometimes i think it can be
prohibitive
to the wider public to access these
matters
um if you if you write in a really
technocratic manner
um it it can prevent you from engaging
fully in the process so i i
fundamentally
uh agree with what kind of split jerome
said previously yeah
yeah um i don't know if you can feed
that back to
uh whichever government department
writes these notices mr evanson
yeah we can we can do that yes yeah but
they've all
they've all got phone numbers on them so
if it's double speak
there's a phone number that you can ring
and and that's what's happened on this
occasion
yeah okay yeah um councilwoman's
proposed that we support this
uh stopping up i'll i'll second that so
we'll
go through the uh the process again um
councillor dr barclay are you in favor
of the stocking up
i'm in favour chairman thank you very
much councillor kerry
i'm in bay the chairman thank you
councillor hartley
i'm in favor as well chair thank you
thank you councillor jerome
i'm in favor also chair thank you
councillor morgan
interview chair thank you councillor
procter
also in favor chair thank you councillor
win stanley
davidson thank you councillor thomas
in favor chair thank you councillor
williams
in favor thank you councillor minis
in favor thank you thank you and i'm in
favor so that is unanimous
that stopping up is supported by the
planning committee
we've got one other item of business i
think we can squeeze it in
uh miss coley um
if if we could chairman it shouldn't
take um um
for too long anyway yep that's the end
of the agenda proper but miss cole is
going to
give us some more information miss coley
yeah i just i just want to advise
members of the committee about a change
to this
to the scheme of delegation or the
planning committee which is going to be
put to
all council uh later in the month
and it relates to those applications
which are submitted by
officers employed by the council which
includes um
includes teachers and teaching
assistants at the at the borough state
schools
um so just share my screen with you and
show you um
what what is proposed at the moment um
no matter what job you have for traffic
council
if you put a planning application in uh
your application has to come to planning
committee
um and that includes somebody for whom
the their only
contact with the planning process is
submitting that planning application
uh they have they have literally nothing
to do with this otherwise
um and and as we've found over the last
few months we've had
numerous of those applications and have
struggled to get through through some of
those and there have been delays to
decision making
we're not proposing that all of those be
delegated to officers but that's a
more proportionate approach is taken to
focus on those where where an officer
could
genuinely have have a prejudicial
interest because they have
some involvement in in the planning
process through
through their uh through their job role
um
so so what i put up in front of you is
what is what is proposed
um and i'll just highlight that's the
extra bit
so the two bit the the one and two where
the
officers got a personal peculiar
interest and the development on behalf
of the council including the school
um is already in there so we're adding
this bit so it relates only to
applications
for household development they wouldn't
be referred to committee unless
the officer was in the place directorate
so that's
the planning service but it also
includes environment environmental
health
um and um and strategic planning
strategic growth
and anybody in regulatory services uh
because we are one directorate of course
and uh and often those offices are
making comments on planning applications
as consultancies employing governance
because
obviously their involvement through the
committee process and then a blanket for
any head of service or above
any in any directorate as they may they
may come
as a result of their seniority and also
any other employee um who has
involvement in determination of planning
applications so for example there's
we have colleagues in education who make
comments on on the need for school
places we would expect their
applications to come to planning
committee
and um in the cases where we have one
more one or more objection
uh that has been received this is um
that is material so in the same way that
only one applicant one objection
triggers uh the referral council own
application to planning committee
then uh only one objection would trigger
one of these
officer um an officer referral
to planning committee in in these
circumstances
so i'll just bring that back back down
again um
i i'm not asking for four members views
on that this evening
this that's a matter to be debated at
full council and
for determination at full council and
you will obviously have your
opportunities to
to speak then but just to make you aware
of that and that's
and that's coming and if the motion is
passed at full council to accept those
changes
then that will come into immediate
effect and we will likely see fewer
officer own applications coming to the
planning committee
thank you chairman thank you miss coley
um we had an application a few months
back
where somebody was um a teaching
assistant in a school
and because they were a teaching
assistant in the school it came to us
to be determined by a planning community
am i am i right in thinking that miss
kohler
uh yes in those circumstances it would
have done this this
new change to the scheme of delegations
meant would mean that unless there was
an objection to that application that
application would not come to us
yeah so the fine detail will come to
full council it's not for us to debate
but
just as an example i remember going and
knocking on that house
and the lady couldn't understand why it
was coming to the planning committee she
was
she was really frightened and uh so i
just explained it to her that because
she uh
if you like worked for the local
education authority
that meant she had it had to come to
planning everybody was fine with it and
it was a very uh um very good
application
and there were no issues so it would
avoid it avoid things like that
happening and
perhaps uh give us more time to deal
with the more um
more important applications but i think
that's the background to it
yes that that is the intention chairman
of particularly while we are working
through these virtual meetings that
uh where we have more limited time and
things are taking a bit longer
okay um yeah council williams i just
wanted that i mean i
i think i approve of uh what what's been
proposed
but my mother was for uh well three
decades a trafford
lea primary school teacher and in
practice you have no
relationship whatsoever with traffic
council but i'm just wondering if
um it could be fed back if we could get
some clarification about what staff sit
under the
place directorate because in my head i'm
not entirely clear about which
departments it were so if um
prior to full council when it comes to
full council that could just be fed back
to us that'd be appreciated thank you
yes sir that that's fine i mean in in
short it's pla it's planning and
development
my service is strategic growth stephen
james service
regulatory services um which is um
which is nigel smith's service plus the
amy highway so chris morris and sharon
walls team
the highways officers for example jeff
is not an employee of the council
uh anything he submitted and it doesn't
live in traffic but nonetheless would
come to committee because of his
interest in
in planning applications but we would we
would take those on a case to case back
case-by-case basis but amy employees
would not be caught by this in any event
yeah um for for for the likes of me mr
crawley can we could we have examples of
that in action
when the new proposals if they were
approved what what what effect that
would be just
just simple examples so we can
understand him i'm conscious uh dr
barclay's got to leave us
because dr barclay so um i have no other
items on the agenda
i don't think we need a review tonight i
think we're all getting into the swing
of this
and um i'd like to declare the meeting
closed
and thank you for your attendance and i
look forward to seeing you again soon
thank you very much
thank you